18 شهرا مرت على الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان
صعدت بعده مباشره حركه طالبان الى السلطه
مغيره المشهد السياسي بشكل جذري في البلد
الذي عان لسنوات
الانسحاب الامريكي فاجا الحكومه السابقه
في افغانستان وفق تقرير حكومي نشرته صحيفه
وولو
التقرير الذي جرى بطلب من الكونجرس
الامريكي والذي سيناقشه قريبا اتهم
البنتاجون بعدم التعاون مع التحقيق حول
انهيار الجيش الافغاني وانه لم يقدم الدعم
الامني للحكومه الافغانيه السابقه كما وعد
ضمن بنود الانسحاب مما سمح بانهيار الجيش
والحكومه وصعود طالبان الى السلطه خلال
ايام معدوده
كما اشار الى تقديم البنتاجون لاجابات غير
كامله على الاسئله لترد وزاره الدفاع
بدورها انها تعاونت مع التحقيق قائله انها
قدمت ردودا مكتوبه على اسئله المفتش العام
نقلا عن التقرير الامريكي القت باللوم على
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن التي لم
تلتزم باتفاق انسحاب القوات الامريكيه بين
طالبان واداره ترامب ما ادى لانتقادات بين
الحزبين الرئيسيين طالت الرئيس بايدن عدا
عن الاتهامات بسوء تخطيط الانسحاب وعدم
الاهتمام بحمايه المتعاقدين الافغان كما
كشفت المعلومات عن ترك الولايات المتحده
معدات عسكريه وراءها في افغانستان بقيمه
تزيد عن سبعه مليارات دولار بين الطائرات
وصواريخ واسلحه ومعدات اتصال
سبعه مليارات دولار من المعدات الصالحه
للعمل من اصل 18 مليارا انفقتها امريكا
على تسليح الجيش الافغاني الذي انهار في
ساعات معدوده
التقرير ختم باهميه عدم تكرار التجربه
الافغانيه في اوكرانيا منبها الى ضروره
مراقبه المساعدات العسكريه التي تقدمها
الولايات المتحده
قائلا ان التورط الامريكي في هذه الصراعات
اظهر عدم القدره على التعلم من الاخطاء